the victory still sinking in for
Liverpool's Trent Alexander Arnold the
post-match moments in the dressing room
were full of mixed emotion Salle's
injury kept him off the pitch but not
from joining the celebrations it was a
wind that defied logic without some of
their best players and with a three goal
deficit Liverpool have had comebacks
before but some say this even smashed
their 2005 miracle of Istanbul as they
want for nil before a stunned Stadium
I don't think Dean you never ever know
when the beaten and I mean obviously
down to the players uncertainly down to
the manager as well but manager Jurgen
Klopp said the team couldn't have done
it without their 12th man
the fans making all the difference
driving the players from the very start
because they're really mentality Giants
it's unbelievable if you go out there
and ask who penny on us I don't think
you'll find it you can find a lot of
people but if you speak to almost any
fan they say it's clops leadership
that's led to their success
it's unbelievable he's like the greatest
manager ever and we just hope they win
the final while Kropp played down
Liverpool's chances the manager of
England's women is using a different
strategy to achieve success
England's defensive rock and captain
Stef Horton will be on the plane to
France a host of high-profile names
throwing their support behind the
lionesses as Phil Neville builds
anticipation around his new squad or
anything can happen we saw that last
night in the Champions League game but
we've got a squad that's highly
motivated we've got a squad full of
world-class players then we've got a
squad that's now I believe got the
belief and confidence to go to a World
Cup to be successful Liverpool has
always been passionate about its
football but the atmosphere at this
semi-final was something special
something many say they haven't seen the
likes of before there was a belief a
confidence from a powerful crowd of fans
and a manager who understood the
importance of harnessing that Merseyside
spirit
Spurs may be inspired by Liverpool's
comeback as they face aiex
tonight but it's a tough act to follow
the pressure on for Tottenham to make it
an All England Champions League final
Sallie Lockwood Sky News and field